bonjour et bienvenue pour cette option
soit aujourd'hui on s'attaque à un gros
morceau une pièce maîtresse de la
science puisqu'il va s'agir de passer à
l'épreuve du feu la théorie qui est
certainement la plus consensuelle et la
plus ardemment défendu par les galeries
roses de la vierge
j'ai nommé la théorie darwinienne de
l'évolution des espèces
la science c'est savoir se remettre en
question le bon scientifique ne cherche
pas à prouver qu'il a raison avant
d'avoir écarté toutes les possibilités
qu'ils aient tort
en d'autres termes une bonne théorie est
une théorie qu'on a d'abord essayé de
démolir de toutes ses forces par tous
les moyens même en lui faisant écouter
miley cyrus surtout en lui faisant
écouter miley cyrus
avant de se rendre compte qu'en fait
elle a résisté vaches pour revenir parce
que pour les scientifiques il n'y a pas
36 façons de savoir si on peut esquiver
une balle avant quand cela tire dans le
pied il faut essayer la théorie de
l'évolution n'est pas irréfutables elle
a ses limites des points faibles des
piliers qui si on parvient à les faire
céder seront s'écrouler tout l'édifice
vers minuit dans cette vidéo nous allons
donc vous présenter les six meilleures
façons de dynamiter ses piliers et de
passer la théorie de darwin à la
moulinette up pour voir dans quel état
il ressort qu on s intéressera ainsi
qu'à l'évolution que nous opposerons à
la fixité des espèces l'origine de la
vie c'est un autre problème
certes l'hypothèse fixiste ne permet pas
de résoudre cette énigme
sauf par l'intervention d'événements
surnaturels et l'hypothèse
évolutionniste peine à la résoudre par
des modèles encore largement théorique
nous ne nous intéresserons pas non plus
au dessein intelligent une petite
fantaisie mêlant maladroitement
événements surnaturels et évolution des
espèces
ici il s'agira donc de savoir comment
démontrer scientifiquement qu'une
plusieurs ont même toutes les espèces
qui peuplent notre planète n'ont jamais
évolué c'est déjà bien assez vaste
programme
on vous verrez non parce que des
démonstrations bas de plafond qui
tiennent pas la route allant du résident
l'obscur en passant par le capilotractée
l on se serait presque convaincant ce
n'était pas de si mauvaise foi il en
existe des brouettes cosmique à foison
tenait avant d'attaquer la vraie science
voici deux exemples d'arguments qui ont
l'air pas si mal voire scientifique à
première vue mais qui en fait ne casse
pas trois pattes à un canard
ouais le premier est celui faisant appel
aux principes physiques de la
thermodynamique l'évolution des espèces
selon cet argument créerait de l'ordre
de la complexité si vous voulez dans un
univers
air où la simplicité semble régner et
serait donc contraire au principe de la
thermodynamique
pour faire simple l'évolution serait
tout bonnement impossible selon les lois
de la physique
ça sonne très sérieux pour peu qu'on
sache ce que sont ces principes mais en
fait il n'ya même pas besoin de les
connaître pour se rendre compte que ça
ne marche pas en effet il convient de
préciser que tous les principes de la
thermodynamique commence par la
sacro-sainte introduction dans un
système clos et à l' équilibre
c'est à dire dans un système isolé et
stable ces principes s'appliquent donc
très bien sur le contenu de type
d'avoirs aux pâquis hermétiquement fermé
perdu dans le vide spatial
mais pas du tout sur terre où la
biosphère reçoit on continue de
l'énergie provenant du soleil et de la
matière venant des météorites
c'est donc tout sauf un système clos et
à l' équilibre par définition les
principes de la thermodynamique ne
s'applique pas dans le cadre des êtres
vivants et de leur évolution suppose et
le second brevet argument est celui dit
de la complexité irréductible
il s'agit ici de dire que la vie telle
que nous la connaissons aujourd'hui est
bien trop complexe et que la nature est
trop bien fait pour avoir évoluer
graduellement en passant par différents
stades intermédiaires moins
perfectionnés l'exemple le plus
couramment citée l'oeil car pour qu'une
image nette se forment la cornée le
cristallin et la rétine doivent avoir
une forme une structure et une position
finement réglé comment une espèce équipé
d'une moitié d'un y aurait pu y voir
clair
ça semble recevable non sauf qu'il est
impossible de prouver que la complexité
irréductible existe en l'occurrence il
ne suffit pas de dire je ne vois pas
comment ses appuis évolué pour prouver
que ça n'a pas évolué vous reconnaîtrez
que c'est assez faible comme
démonstration ne pas comprendre un
phénomène ne prouve pas son inexistence
ça peut donc être trop facilement
balayer même par de mauvais contre
arguments et puis de toute façon il
s'agit pas ici de s'attaquer un par un
aux arguments en faveur de l'évolution
ça prendrait des plans b non là il
s'agit bel et bien de découverts qui
d'un seul coup gagnant dévastateur
réduirait à néant la théorie darwinienne
en prouvant que l'évolution ne peut pas
exister
mais il se fait déjà tard et je sens que
vous trépignez d'impatience
alors voici sans plus attendre les six
fléaux des évolutionnistes les six
découverte qui pourrait invalider
l'évolution des espèces et qui peut être
vous feront rentrer un jour au panthéon
des grands chercheurs dans l'histoire
avec un grand h
comme celui ou celle qui aura détruit le
plus inébranlable des paradigmes en
biologie première découverte un fossile
humain dans le pré courir
si les espèces n'évolue pas alors on
doit être capable de retrouver des
fossiles d'espèces actuelles et ce dans
des strates géologiques de tout temps y
compris dans des couches aussi vieille
que le prix cambrien c'est à dire plus
vieille que 500 millions d'années
trouver un crâne humain l'espèce dans
l'évolution et la plus contestée serait
un must la classe internationale
attention il s'agit bien là de retrouver
un crâne rigoureusement identique à
celui d'un humain d'aujourd'hui pas
quelque chose qui ressemble vaguement
comme c'est le cas pour les soi-disant
fossile vivant en effet laissé la carte
actuelle les coelacanthe car elles sont
en fait deux espèces appartiennent au
genre nati mejia qui est suffisamment
différent de tout laisser là quand
fossiles qu'on a retrouvés pour qu'on
puisse dire qu'il n'existe pas de
fossiles de lahti mejia fossile vivant
sans fossiles
ça la fout mal hein il aime bolelli mule
qui ont l'air de ne pas avoir évolué
vide au-dessus pays ki moon en dessous
possédait autrefois des branchies sur
les pattes qu'elles n'ont plus
aujourd'hui même un tout petit peu
d'évolution c'est déjà trop et là il
faudrait donc un fossile d'humains qui
soit sans équivoque humains peindre sur
le pipec pas un néandertal nom son
identité à homo sapiens ne devrait
laisser aucun doute
attention mesdames et messieurs soyez
attentifs car les roches du précambrien
n'ont pour l'instant livré que des
fossiles de tapis bactérien et d'autres
trucs visqueux uniquement en tout cas
rien ne possédant une colonne vertébrale
donc pour convaincre la communauté
scientifique de l'authenticité de votre
découverte il vous faudra être
irréprochable sur de nombreux points
premièrement il faudrait que
l'authenticité du faux si lui même ne
fasse aucun doute lorsque ans les
conditions de la découverte devront
faire l'objet d'une transparence
complète et d'une traçabilité totale pas
d'approximation
exit les trucs acheter sur les marchés
de chine ou du maroc dont on ne sait que
vaguement d'où ils viennent quand on
sait seulement d'où ils viennent la
couche géologique d'origine fossile
devra être connu et accessible à la
communauté scientifique pour analyse on
sait jamais on pourrait trouver d'autres
lancements et les sédiments contenu à
l'intérieur du fossile devrait être
identique à celui qui compose cette
strate paquet sur d'autres de nettoyer
le fossile à fond là il faut 10 sur du
solide
si la sphère de l'homme de piltdown nous
a bien appris quelque chose c'est qu'un
scientifique même de bonne foi peut être
dupées par ses collaborateurs et se
faire refiler à fossile donc pour
démontrer qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un
fossile il vous faudra être capable de
fournir au moins un scan complet de
votre
découverte afin que sa structure interne
puisse témoigner qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'un assemblage de plusieurs spécimens
c'est dur est devenue une démarche de
routine en paléontologie depuis la
sphère de l'archéo raptor un assemblage
de fossiles de dinosaures à plumes qui
ont été collées tous ensemble par des
marchands pour former à squelette
complet afin de le vendre un meilleur
prix deuxièmement il faudra qu'ils
proviennent des gisements connus les
strates datant du prix cambria sont
rares et ce malgré le fait que cette
période de temps recouvre paradoxalement
les trois quarts de l'histoire de notre
planète
depuis il a pris part de ces terrains
sont faits de granit une roche
magmatique venu des profondeurs de la
terre donc dépourvu de fossiles ce qui
fait que les roches sédimentaires celles
issues des dépôts de surface et les
seuls susceptibles de contenir des
fossiles sont encore plus rares elles
sont bien connues des géologues car ils
contiennent souvent dollars et moi
j'aime bien ça alors donc pendant son
look possible si ça vient d'ailleurs que
de l'un de ces endroits
ces allers simples direction poubelle
j'avais dix poubelles
troisièmement il faudra bien évidemment
car si le point central que vous voulez
démontrer que la datation du fossile ne
laisse aucun doute le mieux serait
d'utiliser la datation absolue si
quelques cristaux de zircon sont
disponibles afin qu un âge minimum
puisse être déterminée avec précision
grâce aux isotopes de l'uranium
d'autres techniques des datations
indépendante devront être pratiquée et
le tout par plusieurs laboratoires
indépendants cétacés très lourd de
conditions et uniquement à ces
conditions qui vous parviendrez à
dissiper n'importe quel doute quant à
votre découverte forcément hors norme
deuxième découverte
l'absence de structures phylogénétique
la ville au génie c'est un peu la
généalogie des espèces vivantes
c'est une technique qui permet de
représenter les liens de parenté entre
espèces sous la forme d'un arbre mais un
arbre phylogénétique n'est pas tout à
fait un arbre généalogique
voici l'arbre généalogique qui m'unit à
ma famille et voici l'arbre
phylogénétique qui m'unit aux mêmes
personnes et constater qu'on ne sait pas
qui descendit dans ce deuxième homme
tout ce qui peut être dit c'est que je
suis plus étroitement apparentées à ma
mère kmmg en mer mais plus rien ne
permet de dire que ma mère et mon
ancêtre
elle pourrait tout aussi bien être ma
soeur ces timbres nous dit juste qu'il
doit exister un ancêtre commun entre
mais comme on ne sait pas quel est cet
ancêtre commun
alors on parlera d'ancêtres communs
hypothétique dans le cadre de la théorie
de l'évolution quand les biologistes et
les paléontologues comparé la
morphologie ou les gènes des espèces ils
obtiennent des arbres similaire mais si
les espèces ne voulut pas les unes des
autres
alors il ne peut pas y avoir dans cette
rue comme un don qu'il ne peut pas y
avoir deux rames ira cette arme dont il
n'y a pas d'arbres du tout en fait c'est
un râteau ou un panier c'est comme vous
voulez s'il n'y a pas d'évolution alors
il ne peut pas y avoir de structuration
de l'adn de la morphologie en fonction
des histoires communes à ces espèces
puisque ces espèces ne doivent par
définition n'avoir rien en commun durant
les années 80 et 90 une découverte a
fait trembler les évolutionnistes la
découverte du groupe d afro terre vous
ne savez pas ce que c'est et rassurez
vous car jusqu'à très récemment les
biologistes ne savait pas non plus il
s'agit d'un groupe de mammifères
partageant un patrimoine génétique en
commun mais rassemblant des espèces
anatomiquement si différentes les unes
des autres que cela semblait aller à
l'encontre de toute forme de logique
évolutive sens j'ai un peu dans les
affronter on retrouve les gigantesques
éléphants les minuscules haha trompe des
tops de ré à fourmilier african mais
l'oryctérope d'un sérieusement sa liste
mais oui je suis sûr que tu connais
celui de la panthère rose ou bien arthur
des produits de la mer j'ai nommé les
siréniens des sortes de marmottes à
trois doigts qu'on appelle les dames ans
et enfin des insectivores aux airs de
pokémon dans le si un peu précieux que
vous n'avez jamais entendu parler les
temps avec voilà tout ça selon la
théorie de l'évolution là toutes ces
bêtes là c'était ses adjoints d'ancêtre
commun
1 ça fait rêver hein
votre mission si toutefois vous décidez
de réfuter l'évolution sera de démontrer
que des excentricités est telle que les
afro terre sont omniprésentes dans la
nature
il vous faudra donc séquencé le génome
entier c'est à dire l'ensemble de l'adn
d'un maximum d'espèces vivantes et de
multiplier les analyse phylogénétique
jusqu à démontrer qu'on n'obtient jamais
deux fois le même arbre vous feriez
ainsi la démonstration que l'homme est
assez différente h à poser ou d'une
bactérie que d'un arbre culte bull mais
nous sommes tous très différents les uns
des autres ce qui démontrerait coca lien
de parenté de bonnes chances ce message
aux plus grands pour ça qu'ils m'ont ça
a presque l'air samedi comme ça mais en
réalité va falloir vous accrocher car si
l'arbre phylogénétique du vivant il faut
alors cela implique que tu as totalité
de l'apn des jeunes de toutes les
espèces qui ont été étudiées jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est à dire quelques
milliers nous a menti ce qui n'est pas
peu dire
eh ouï dire que les afro terre ont un
ancêtre commun ça paraît grotesque à
première vue mais il faut bien vous
rendre compte que face à un truc pareil
les scientifiques n'ont pas opiné du
chef en disant ok ouais bon là c'est
cool j'aime bien comme ça allez on garde
non ils ont potassé leur fiche
revérifier la totalité du génome de
toutes les façons possibles et
imaginables péter et répété leur analyse
sur toutes les espèces de mammifères
connus pour voir si on retrouvait
toujours la même chose et les jeunes
sont unanimes les affreux terre partage
bien un patrimoine génétique unique qui
s'il n'est pas arrêté d'un ancêtre
commun n'aurait que très difficilement
pu se retrouver là à l'identique
complètement par hasard le vieil adage
c'est ce qu'il y à l'intérieur qui
compte n'aura jamais été aussi vrai
qu'avec les afro terre en tout cas si on
accepte l'explication évolutif il
existerait sur notre planète entre 8 et
30 millions d'espèces mais on en connaît
qu'un million tout le reste nous est
inconnue il s'agirait pour la plupart
d'insectes de plantes et surtout de
bactéries de ce million d'espèces le
génome d'uniquement quelques milliers
d'entre elles est à l'heure actuelle
décrypter ce qui laisserait une
confortable marge de manoeuvre à qui
voudrait démontrer que l'ajout de
nouvelles espèces à ce qu'on appelle
l'arbre de la vie
le démolir est
une fois de plus la traçabilité et
l'origine des séquences adn que vous
présenterez devra être irréprochable
les séquences génétiques devons être
extraites de vos échantillons par
plusieurs laboratoires indépendants et
devront être versés sur une base de
données en ligne et en libre accès pour
tous comme jane bang par exemple afin
que n'importe qui mais surtout d'autres
scientifiques bien sûr puisse vérifier
vos résultats
il vous faudra donc renoncer à la
paternité de toutes vos belles
découvertes et accepter qu'on passe
derrière vous pour vérifier tout ce que
vous faites c'est ça la science et ce
n'est qu'à ce prix que les biologistes
accepteront vos conclusions car en
vérité les files aux généticiens sont
plutôt habitués à ce que l'ajout des
espèces nouvellement découverte
bouleverse ce qu'ils croyaient savoir de
l'arbre de la vie
cela a par exemple été le calquant la
découverte des bactéries l'eau qui a
modifié plus d'un tiers de la topologie
d'un arbre de la vie
de plus les généticiens savent que
parler d'arbres du vivant n'est pas tout
à fait vrai car dans le détail il y à
des échanges entre les branches de
l'arbre vo cellule contient des
mitochondries qui sont anciennes
bactéries reconverti en symbiote leur
adn est typiquement celui d'une balle
terry pourtant on en retrouve des
morceaux dans notre propre adn à nous
des gènes de deux bactéries dans notre
génome pour les biologistes l'arbre de
la vie et donc en fait un réseau ou plus
poétiquement un delta de la vie avec des
ramifications qui se croisent pour
surprendre la communauté scientifique
il va nous falloir découvrir un maximum
de nouvelles espèces alors laissé tomber
la bleuse et enfiler plutôt vos bottes
parce qu'avant même de travailler l'adn
dans un laboratoire il va vous falloir
patauger dans la gadoue de la forêt
amazonienne à la recherche de nouvelles
espèces et dépêchez vous de temps qu'il
en reste encore un peu de forêt
troisième découverte
la sélection naturelle n'existait pas
la sélection naturelle c'est un peu le
coeur de l'évolution
le saint graal dans le cadre de la
théorie de l'évolution c'est elle qui
donne une direction à l'évolution en ne
permettant pas à toutes les
excentricités que le hasard des
mutations peut produire de se perpétrer
les mutations délétère où n'est
avantageux s'élimine d'elle-même d'où le
côté naturel de la sélection tandis que
les autres se maintiennent dans les
populations de voir se répandre mais
cela prend plusieurs générations dans le
cadre de la théorie de l'évolution
si la sélection naturelle n'existait pas
alors les espèces évoluerez tous azimuts
sans possibilité de s'adapter réellement
et finir et donc tout par s'éteindre
dans cette situation le lapin n'est pas
en concurrence avec le renard il est en
concurrence avec les autres lapins seuls
les lapins les plus habiles à semer les
renards se vivront au renard et se
reproduiront donnant naissance à des
petits lapinous toujours plus rapides et
bondissants mais si la sélection
naturelle n'existe pas si la chasse du
renard n'applique aucune pression de
sélection et tuent les lapins qu importe
leur habilité alors les lapins
évolueront sans jamais s'adapter et
certainement finiront par disparaître
c'est en tout cas le scénario que la
théorie de l'évolution laisse envisager
sans sélection naturelle pas
d'adaptation dont pas d'évolution sur le
long terme
donc si on démontre que la sélection
naturelle n'existe pas alors on démontre
que l'évolution tout entier avec une
mystification
c'est aussi simple que ça un guerrier
rose de l'évolution vous répondrai que
pour que la sélection naturelle n'existe
pas il faut que la façon de mourir ou du
moins de ne pas parvenir à se reproduire
soit totalement aléatoire c'est à dire
qu'elles ne puissent pas être évités par
une quelconque aptitudes des espèces
vivantes genre des plus minimes et
théories qui s'abatterait opi où la
foudre et qui frapperait n'importe où
n'importe quand et n'importe qui ouais
mais maintenant vous savez que ce type
d'argument basé sur le jeu comprend pas
comment ça peut exister alors ça
n'existe pas n'a pas de valeur de
démonstration mettons plutôt en place un
protocole scientifique bien sérieux qui
pourraient nous permettre de fournir une
vraie réponse comment démontrer que la
sélection naturelle n'existe pas la
sélection naturelle et à fait le même
d'élimination non aléatoire des
variantes qui sont les moins avantageux
en gros si t'es pas bon dans ce que tu
fais tu sors enfin je veux dire tu te
reproduit pas donc il faudrait créer
plein de souris de laboratoire mutante
des mutants un peu naze mais aussi des
mutants enrochements balèze ce genre d
mal avec un plein de testostérone et
puis des femelles
de produire beaucoup de l'aide ça ça
doit pouvoir se faire sans moi sans vie
de nabeul et puis après on les lâche
dans la nature et on voit si elles se
reproduisent aussi bien que les noms
mutante
si la sélection naturelle n'existe pas
alors les souris mutantes qu'elles
soient bonnes ou mauvaises produiront
autant de descendants que les individus
normand pour une fois c'est simple et le
résultat sera sans équivoque comme de
mettre la théorie de la gravitation
universelle à l'épreuve en lançant une
souris en l'air et on met la voyance
jamais retomber quatrième découverte
la rareté des mutations bénéfiques
l'adn c'est le support de la vie notre
code barre les instructions écrites en
minuscule à l'intérieur de nos cellules
et qui permettent de construire faire
fonctionner et entretenir les êtres
vivants que nous sommes dans le cadre de
la théorie de l'évolution ce sont les
changements réguliers dans le code de
l'adn les fameuses mutation génétique
qui alimente l'évolution des espèces les
mutations s'accumulant les populations
finissent par diverger ne plus se
ressembler et finalement deuxième de
nouvelles espèces si la sélection
naturelle est le moteur de l'adaptation
les mutations génétiques en sont
incontestablement le carburant si nous
sommes tous différents et c'est un fait
c'est entre autres parce que l'adn mute
entre 20 et 30 mutations nous distingue
en moyenne de nos parents mais la
théorie de l'évolution n'en est pas vrai
pour autant car ces variations de l'adn
pourrait fort bien ne pas avoir d'effet
sur le long terme
il y aurait quelques micros variations
locales de la micro évolution mais les
mutations pourraient par exemple le ca
nul et entre elles ce qui résulterait à
la global fixité des espèces l'absence
de maquereaux évolution dans le cadre de
la théorie de l'évolution pour que la
macro évolution et lieu et qu'une espèce
évolué visiblement il faut qu'une série
de mutations avantageuse soit
positivement sélectionnés par la
sélection naturelle ne salent tous
porteurs des mutations des bonnes des
mauvaises et d'autres qui n'ont pas
d'importance mais démontré la trop
grande rareté des mutations bénéfiques
par rapport aux autres mettraient à mal
l'hypothèse de l'évolution des espèces
le problème c'est qu'il est quasiment
impossible de définir ce qu'est une
mutation bénéfique
prenez par exemple le site isme il
s'agit d'une maladie génétique qui dès
colore la peau et les poils mais
contrairement à l'albinisme les animaux
comme les gens qui en sont atteints en
souffrent pas trop voir s'en sortait
très bien comme la top model deviendra
forest cette maladie peut s'avérer un
inconvénient dans les milieux où le
soleil tape fort et où la peau a besoin
d'être protégée mais au contraire elle
peut favoriser l'absorption des uv
nécessaire à la synthèse de la vitamine
d sous les latitudes moins clémente ou
tout simplement servir de camouflage
inconvénients d'à côté mais avantage de
l'autre il en va de même toit la
drépanocytose une très grave maladie du
sang héréditaire mais qui dans certaines
conditions confère une protection
naturelle contre le paludisme comment
dire si cette mutation est bénéfique ou
pas tantôt c'est une maladie tantôt
c'est un bouclier naturel contre une
autre maladie
un autre exemple le gène à paul un
apollo un nom apple
sa mutation empêchent le bon
fonctionnement des reins mais la même
mutation protège de la maladie du
sommeil
le bénéfice d'une mutation n'est donc
qu'une question de contexte c'est
pourquoi à vouloir démontrer la rareté
des mutations dit entre guillemets
bénéfique vous risquez de vous casser
les dents nous vous recommandons donc de
passer votre chemin
5e découverte une diminution de la
biodiversité
c'est un fait les espèces disparaissent
et les traces indiscutable d'espèces qui
ont un temps existé mais n'existe plus
en préserver dans la roche
si les espèces n'évolue pas pour donner
naissance à de nouvelles espèces alors
la biodiversité ne peut que diminuer au
fil des temps géologiques
c'est en tout cas ce qui se passerait si
aucune nouvelle espèce n'arrive sur
terre autrement
il suffit donc de jeter un coup d'oeil
dans le registre fossile de compter le
nombre d'espèces disparues qui sont
connus tracer une courbe de la
biodiversité au fil du temps et de voir
comment elle varie si elle est restée
constante ou à augmenter c'est perdu
mais si elle a diminué alors c'est gagné
en utilisant le registre fossiles marins
le paléontologue live band baleine a
calculé que la longévité moyenne d'une
espèce était de 2 à 10 millions d'années
environ
imaginez alors combien d'espèces aurait
parcouru le monde il y a trois milliards
d'années le travail s'annonce titanesque
néanmoins ne vous faites pas de cheveux
car de paléontologues numéro et c'est
que ce qui nous ont déjà machy tout le
boulot ils ont eux-mêmes utiliser toutes
les données disponibles dans les années
80 afin de tracer la dite courbes et
voici le résultat
la biodiversité sur terre semble avoir
plutôt globalement augmenté au fil du
temps en tout cas elle n'a pas diminué
mais bon en même temps c'est le coq date
d'il ya trente ans donc il n'est pas
exclu que les découvertes plus récentes
et quelque peu fait changer la tendance
de plus le fait qu'on retrouve plus
d'espèces dans les niveaux de plus en
plus récents pourraient être simplement
dû à une meilleure préservation des
fossiles dans les strates les moins
anciennes d'ailleurs ce ne sont pas des
espèces qui figurent sur ce graphique
mais bien des familles il y a donc un
manque d'information et surtout la
biodiversité actuelle est largement
dominé par les plantes les insectes et
les bactéries qui tous se fossilise
assez mal et ne sont pas représentés sur
cette coupe à wii uniquement les
invertébrés et les protozoaires mara
sont représentés ici donc cette courbe
souffre de nombreux biais et ne
reflètent qu'une petite partie de la
vérité des défauts qu'il vous faudra
corriger si vous vous lancez dans cette
belle aventure et vous vous sentez le
courage de hanter les bibliothèques
universitaires afin d'éplucher la longue
littérature à la recherche de toutes les
espèces fossiles qui ont jusqu'à
aujourd'hui été recensés
6e découverte l'existence d'une espèce
100% altruiste
selon la théorie de l'évolution des
êtres vivants sont des machines à
transmettre leurs gènes
la reproduction voilà tout ce qui compte
et tous les moyens sont bons pour
favoriser sa survie et maximiser ses
chances de transmettre son patrimoine
génétique à ses descendants
le crime le vol mais aussi la
coopération les vitalisme et pourquoi
pas la symbiose
elle reste évolutif dans profitable tant
que tout le monde y trouve son compte et
tant qu'il ya un avantage égoïste pour
chacun mais qu'une espèce agissant pour
cent au bénéfice d'une autre sans en
tirer la moindre contrepartie ça la
théorie de l'évolution ne le prévoit pas
et pour tout vous dire elle prévoit tout
le contraire sa disparition une espèce
ne peut évoluer pour une autre qu'elle
même pour ceux qui auraient du mal à
visualiser le concept prenons un exemple
accessibles à tout à chacun ce le moment
de parler football
prénom une équipe de foot onze joueurs
quand ils gagnent ils sont grassement
payés et quand ils perdent ils sont
moins bien payés la situation optimale
pour l'équipe c'est que tout le monde se
donne à fond et alors c'est la gloire et
l'opulence assuré mais dans la réalité
ça ne se passe jamais comme ça il y en a
toujours un au moins pour ne rien
glander ne pas bouger ses fesses et
encaisser les gains et toute la gloire
en profitant du dur labeur des autres
lui peut tout avoir sans rien faire à
quoi bon courir
la situation la plus optimale pour
l'équipe n'est pas la meilleure pour
l'individu ce qui favorise les
profiteurs et les tricheurs mais
maintenant imaginez la situation
contraire un virtuose du ballon rond un
joueur hors pair qui ferait gagner
l'équipe à tous les coups mais qui
jouerait pour rien pas un rond ni argent
ni gloire à la fin du match
iran balle ses crampons fait la bise à
tout le monde et s'en va sans demander
son reste
alors ce joueur à la générosité hors du
commun serait un altruiste un vrai et
dans la nature ce genre de comportement
n'a que des inconvénients non mais
imaginez seulement la tête de sa femme
quand elle le voit rentrer le soir à la
maison sans un sou une espèce ou même un
individu au sein d'une espèce donnée qui
agirait comme ce joueur de foot au
mépris de sa propre existence
uniquement pour le bien des autres
disparaîtrait aussi tôt ainsi une espèce
dont les individus sacrifierait
sciemment leur capacité de reproduction
à ceux d'une
autres espèces auxquelles ils ne sont
pas apparentés et ce sans en tirer aucun
bénéfice direct ou indirect que ce soit
ne peut pas exister
en tout cas pas si l'évolution est vrai
pour faire simple
découvrez une espèce d'antilope qui
offre son corps en pâture aux lions sans
la moindre résistance si vous ferez la
preuve que cette espèce particulière ne
peut pas être issu du processus évolutif
tels que les scientifiques d'aujourd'hui
l'entendent
même si comme nous l'avons déjà dit la
plus grande majorité des espèces
vivantes
reste encore à découvrir cela ne
s'annonce pas de tout repos en effet
beaucoup de relations entre espèces
donne l'impression d'être altruiste
alors qu'elles sont en fait égoïste chez
certaines espèces d'oiseaux à l'individu
peut faire la sentinelle il fait le guet
et se sacrifie pendant que les autres
boivent mangent dorment et se
reproduisent tranquillement mais cet
oiseau fait partie de la même espèce que
ses congénères et bien souvent de la
même fratrie ce qui a l'inconvénient
pour lui reste donc un avantage général
pour le groupe et a fortiori pour
l'espèce entière donc ces jeunes y
trouvent leur compte mais indirectement
le mutualisme et la symbiose sont des
relations à bénéfice réciproque qui
confère aux deux protagonistes des
avantages d'égoïste dans le cas du
parasitisme lettres parasites et ne se
laisse pas gentiment affectée et ne se
rend pas sans combattre
on pourrait croire que les animaux de
compagnie se sacrifie pour le bien de
l'homme mais il n'en est rien même eux
dont l'origine n'a pourtant pas grand
chose à voir avec la sélection naturelle
tirent un avantage reproductive de leur
domestication
il n'y a qu'à voir l'immense nombre de
chiens de chevaux et de poule qui
parcourt le monde par rapport à la
quantité de leurs homologues sauvage et
cela s'applique aussi aux plantes comme
les céréales qui les nourrissent
gentiment mais ils trouvent aussi leur
compte en matière de reproduction et en
termes de protection contre les insectes
et les intempéries pour éviter tous ces
écueils
il vous faudra donc découvrir deux
espèces bien distinctes engagé dans ce
type de relations l'une exploitants
l'autre pour se nourrir ou se reproduire
ou les deux vos meilleures chances sont
évidemment parmi les micro-organismes
oublier les lions et les gazelles il
vous faudra ensuite démontré qu'il n'y a
aucune chance pour que le protagoniste
exploiter tire le moindre avantage de
cette relation ni directement ni
indirectement et qu'il ne s'en protège
pas non plus ainsi se défendre ça marche
pas enfin il vous faudra démontrer que
cette situation est durable dans le
temps et pas simplement temporaire et si
les espèces exploitées fini par
disparaître suite aux mauvais
traitements que j'ai un fish d'autres au
contraire a fini par apprendre à s'en
défendre sa trouvera rien du tout le
monde des micro-organismes que dis-je
mondy
des êtres unicellulaires conserve encore
beaucoup de ses secrets alors aux lakers
car c'est certainement l'une de vos
meilleures chances de rentrer un jour
dans l'histoire
en conclusion si une seule de ses six
découvertes venait un jour à être fait
en remplissant toutes les conditions de
validité que nous venons d'énoncer
réussi alors il est certain que les
tenants de la théorie de l'évolution
pourront commencer à sérieusement
remettre en question ce qu'il croit
savoir sur l'origine des espèces
vous avez toutefois certainement
soupirait de résignation devant
l'immensité des tâches à accomplir pour
qui souhaiterait rentrer dans l'histoire
en s'attaquant à la validité de la
théorie de l'évolution
et c'est qu'il faut prendre la pleine
mesure et qualité de cette théorie car
malgré ses imperfections la théorie
darwinienne de l'évolution des espèces
ne reste pas moins une théorie très
aboutie et au pouvoir descriptif
explicatifs et prédictifs très efficace
mais ce n'est pas parce que jusqu'à
présent elle a résisté aux assauts de
toutes les nouvelles découvertes
scientifiques ayant pu la valider qu'il
faut pour autant qu'elle se repose sur
ses lauriers
il ne faut donc pas hésité à secouer
vigoureusement ce vieil arbre qui est la
théorie de l'évolution pour voir s'il
est encore solide
par ailleurs on en attend pas moins
détonnant des théories alternatives d'en
faire autant avec leur arbre à eux qui
sont autrement plus anciens c'était bien
marrant c'est petit épisode à contre
courant la fin de sa mission donner
envie à plus importante des découvertes
qui prouverait que les espèces n'évolue
pas avant quelle découverte
tout bêtement démontrer scientifiquement
de façon brutale et sable et
reproductibles par chacun l'existence
réelle est bien palpable une force pour
obliger les espèces à rester fixe
c'est pas faux